- Congratulations.
My nephew is
a sophomore at UCLA.
I'll have him
take your little class.
- Uh, you could,
or you could--
and I mean this
in the nicest possible way--
mind your business/
shut the [bleep] up.
Sorry.
- Did you know that apparently
I have to get a job
or I go back
on house arrest?
Well, too sad, so bad,
Sister Sergeant.
I ain't doing it.
It's bull[bleep]!
- You want to talk b-[bleep]?
I did what you told me to do.
I Pfeiffed it out.
And thanks to your brain-dead
brain's advice,
my dream job
went down the dream drain.
- I am very mad and very upset
about everything you just said,
but I would also like
to switch gears
and say how happy I am
that you didn't get it,
because now
you can stay with me
and you can go with me
to the Army surplus store,
and I can park my wheelchair,
and you can change my catheter.
- I would never, ever stay here,
even if you paid me,
which you already did.
I would rather kill myself than
stay here another day, bitch.
- Excuse me?
- I called you a bitch.
- Well, you know what, bitch?
Why don't you get in a car
and find a cliff,
and then,
when you find that cliff,
take the car that you're in
and drive off of a cliff,
you freaking bitch?
- Good advice. I will.
And you know what else?
- What?
- I'll land in the ocean
because I am smart enough
to build a car that floats,
"Chitty Chitty Bang Bang"-style,
you [bleep] bitch.
- Okay, well, I have
several shark homies
that I can reach out to,
and they could smell you
and lead me to you,
you [bleep] bitch.
- Well, then, I'll give 'em
a little shark sleeping pill,
and they'll be all like,
zzz, [chomping],
you Shirley Temple-headed bitch!
- I am not a drink!
Cheteran was right.
You have no idea
what I've been through.
- And what is that?
3 ounces of weed
and a box of honuts?
- What are honuts?
- Donuts for whores.
- All right.
Attention, everyone.
Tonight is about
my lovely daughter, Gene...
- [loud fake cough]
The nightmare.
- And her brilliant tutor,
Roberta.
- [fake cough] The nightmare.
- I already did that.
- Now, I understand Robert
has prepared a little something,
have you, Robert?
- No.
I have something prepared
that's better, so can I...
- All right, honey.
Yeah, go ahead.
- This is better than
whatever Billie was gonna say.
I just wanted to say
thank you to all the people
that helped me
through my sentence.
Uh, of course there's
my loving father, Dad Russell.
[applause]
Um, big ups to my awesome
stepmother from another brother.
Where's Tanzy?
- You're welcome.
[applause]
- Uh, the mail guy
always brought cool letters
and fun coupons, so let's
give it to--give it up for him.
[applause]
And, oh, my gosh.
I almost forgot
the most important person.
Wow.
She's the, uh, wind
beneath my chicken wings.
My best friend
and the person
I trust the most.
Joy.
[cheers and applause]
Thanks, Joy. Thank you.
- Excuse me.